can you actually be double-jointed it's
an odd question because you first have
to ask what does double-jointed actually
mean the term itself sounds like you
might have twice as many joints as
normal or maybe it means that you have a
special double joint that's more
flexible than the rest
sadly double-jointed mystery box it
actually means that you're born
unusually flexible physicians call it
joint hypermobility or hypermobility
syndrome and it comes in two main forms
either the collagen and the ligaments
that connects your bones is looser than
most which explains how some people can
touch their thumb to their forearm or
your bones are actually shaped
differently especially the ones in
places like your shoulders and hips
which have ball and socket joints
hypermobile people tend to have
shallower sockets which means they can
do things like dislocate their shoulder
without pain or bend down and touch the
floor with their palms
without practice this sort of inherit
flexibility can be extremely
advantageous for certain athletes
dancers and musicians but studies have
shown that it may also come with a price
first it seems to take a toll on the
body raising a person's risk of knee
sprains ankle sprains and osteoarthritis
of the hands and shoulders but a growing
body of research also suggests it can
affect the mind
one study in 1998 found that patients
with anxiety were sixteen times more
likely to also have hypermobile joints
this could be because of the loose
collagen and many hypermobile people
effects blood flow blood will more
likely accumulate in the legs which puts
more stress on the heart for circulation
and pushes the body to the verge of
fight-or-flight which means it takes
very little to induce anxiety or panic
psychiatrist Jessica ecklie's of the
University of Sussex says joint high
permeability has an impact on the whole
body and not just joints an estimated 3
to 20 percent of the population is hyper
mobile or double-jointed
you